I got RPG I got it okay where am I
why do I seem why do I seem so short
right here I don't know is it just my
normal existence I mean it was just like
the way that this patio was built I
thought it was I thought I was very
short
nowhere nowhere no bottles going nowhere
sir bottles did you hide in the snow no
run around no I kept running oh [ __ ]
there's a down stick there's a sewer
well we'd better go in the sewer loops
around you can get back out the other
side way I know you're right there oh I
got one there's a bottle there's a
bottle on the rod oh it's a good one no
it's good one good job Wade good job
Wade doughnuts later wood you got one
more Oh women loose nice right that's
offering you the garbage can just to the
other side of the fence yeah and the
garbage can that's running around that's
your clue okay running around garbage
can I'm the map I'm everything the map
you look like you're having a cracker
time whoa hey whoa what the hell man
you're looking at frit i'm weightily
right yeah alright you're talking about
Bob I couldn't actually see you I just
assumed you were looking at the little
earlier don't even try to cover now
we're on your trail oh you got me I was
present next Oh Lexi I think Mandy's
home what sister barking I'm about to
get swatted or robbed or Mandy's home
[Laughter]
hmm wonder what fresh hell is it so
you're really all given up on that area
already hey there's another R obviously
you were talking about wait a minute
and then one of you stays in the other
area anyway what the hell is that
I just Bob as far as I get through it I
found I found pretty far could throw me
pretty pretty far you know throw it
pretty far
are you already turned a bun if you were
strong enough pretty snow Wade we're
being made a fool of emergency I believe
we're being played Bob is very present
in his current scenario Oh God Oh girls
wait a minute wait wait a minute wait a
minute
did we not even think about this way you
know what I'm gonna go talk to Mandy I'm
so confident about this I'm just gonna
leave it and I'll be back
you guys have a minute to find me wait
oh god oh god
I found another Easter Egg apparently
wait those my name's trying to pick it
up you [ __ ] [ __ ] you picked it up
I didn't get it you got it you son of a
[ __ ] you see from it you stole it from
me
Oh Bob shut up okay where is he what
he's a present right I mean you're the
one who got it no I didn't get nothing
you'd stole it from me you took it from
me
rob me of it all right I didn't get no
no no no you robbed me
it's where what's going on in the area
you're in mark what washer-dryer thing
whoa wait drop the chair on top of him
fine he's always like a washer oh god oh
my god this bobstine you'd have been
cheering if he knew he won good so we
won yeah I just walked off camera and
just came back well I told me use in the
area he fired a grenade it was a
desperate move we were on our last
seconds and we couldn't couldn't do
nothing you'll never find me though I
was an extra washing I'm the ghost of
Christmas past I've just lost to my
memories I'm wallowing in my song heard
a door open this door just opened Bob oh
my god there's a box Bob did you open
this door no I have not opened any doors
you know I keep hearing doors opening I
don't know where weight is but I'm
assuming he's playing off for sale
interior yes oh that's weird
yeah it's a hot dog friend nothing how
you doing Austin I was in the stairwell
on the side and it was a tiny hot dog
and he got away
I saw you wait for a split second you
passed right by me mark would you like a
piece of my soggy buns no I'm just
wallowing in desperation as I usually am
just leave me to my own I'll be fine ah
[ __ ] how are you
nothing and everything knowing knowing
knowing
I'm just over your Newton it's fine go
wait careful we'll miss gravity okay
whoa whoa you fur he's got the moves
oh he's here's mark oh there is Wow
you'll never find me unless you have the
guiding light wing it is so creepy
I know right no though he's a tipos in a
dark [ __ ] Minh corner somewhere well
that would be a weird guess yeah watch
Jack okay wait wait don't kill me don't
kill me yet just I'm cooperating
American we have lots of guns over here
in America I don't know if you know so
political pretty easy to get your hands
okay I've made a mistake I realized the
gravity of my mistake now and I would
like to undo it please okay boobs jump
to make from gravity you know what
Sanibel lady no the same mistake again
Wow where do you say straight like
ridiculous [ __ ] because what's so wait
oh wait wait no I'm not going anywhere
I'm a [ __ ] huge bookshelf but imagine
if I was like up against the wall right
here right like that would totally have
work right sir
really it's just not gonna work
[Laughter]
see your mistake jack was being a green
present anyone would have spotted that a
mile away obviously what was it gonna be
red well I mean if you want it because
people would pick red and dye their hair
that works right now you're so weird man
you're being so weird dude I meant to do
okay we got this oh yeah I'm so good
doing we're gonna win we're doing so
good and win go team Oh No and you know
I owe Sajak especially especially music
good job jack thank you especially to
you you know you know I'm saying Bob I
just feel like we're really gelling as a
team unit you finally made it on the
ramp now you're in the house like how
the doors jiggle like they might open
but obviously yeah look at you guys both
in the keep it up keep it up with the
teamwork Jack we're really we're really
nailing it yeah we got it you guys no
wonder we just got to hang out and wait
for them to kill told you know I'm just
so good I'd rather I didn't fall that's
the thing I just walked into something
else and it killed me
well what the hell happened I was
suicidal you know lesson learned
you know what did I do wrong
ah life oh man
Bob you could just find picking them all
or walking into them yeah
BAM oh well why'd you come in to start
shooting in that room trying to hide
before and I knew that there were too
many things oh I see [ __ ] are you
serious nevermind changed my [ __ ]
mind
the same idea is that a clue are you
twins we are twins we're you could say
we're copies that would be more accurate
if you said that we were copies there's
no sharks on this level copies this
copies that to do it sure yeah wait that
was a bit of a label on no album sharks
copycat sharks copy shark cats I lost
you I wasn't really trying to stay near
you so yeah it sort of just wandered off
there's some ransacking happening over
here I hear some stomping around in my
basement what are you doing in my waters
if I had to deduce something some Shack
something's going on something
something's funky here I'm the king of
these waters you stay out of my way of
the waters I think they're copies turns
into sharks water stars into hentai yeah
wait I I appreciate you thinking outside
of the box but for once in your goddamn
life stay stay in your box
just a car you know sit behind the
dumpster is that easier yeah the red
present that I can see behind the
dumpster moving around well if it's
moving around what do you think now I'm
gonna have to leave this is that's it
that's a trick it's a dirty trick
they're leading us there move around my
guy in the fish tank wiggle II wiggle
get out of my waters you [ __ ] they're
tricking us tricking us yeah being
tricks maybe for once we're actually
telling the truth revolution today
I forgot oh god oh god oh god discovered
who I really am I
from now on tell the truth I find that
extremely hard to believe jack is the Oh
gah dang mark which i think means either
one of you doing walk past the dumpster
with the red truck I wait no man there's
something something there just [ __ ]
with us I know that for certain
[Laughter]
uh-huh hey the prison's on top of this
car
look we're not those ones but my
presence is a present gives my ass
Wow Wow that's that's really harsh man
you could be yeah
this was a friendly game it's just
quoting Kanye I thought he was cool
somebody just saw me I'll jump too but I
don't think it's gonna do that much no
one has even gone inside very much this
time Oh your insight as well maybe I
don't think they're lying that's all a
little bit lying about everything
they're talking about it's all a lie
what probably so think about like
everything that they said and think the
exact opposite of it maybe I'm outside
where the tables are and I'm look at me
maybe I'm a tiny thing hiding underneath
the police car maybe I actually am in
the water in the basement and soda cans
are shorter than the surface of that
water
maybe I'm cheating probably not cheating
I don't that no no that's true
everything said is absolutely untrue
that one of those was exactly where I
currently the only true is though that
you have walked around wait where are
the props we're the premiere the props
oh no my god oh I I told you exactly
where I am I just said take a seat and
you're still outside I said I said what
if I'm up where those table
I'm just a green bottle standing there
watching you [ __ ] what if I'm a tiny
prop hiding underneath the police car or
what if I'm a soda can and the soda cans
are actually shorter than the surface of
the water that's in the basement but
there's car there's no police car I'm
pretty sure this is a police car that is
cheating
that's cheating you up here no mediately
just end everything but that's not what
I wanted to be well
hey whoa no who's this obviously don't
worry I've been there oh come on no come
on no stuck in the wall I I know I
wasn't stuck in the wall but I got stuck
as the bookshelf I only the bookshelf
and I only became the chair as soon as
you walked through the door so I kind of
thought mark would last more than three
seconds it's not no it was just too late
yeah he lied about it being a cop car -
it's no I
I thought it was the cop car that was an
accidental lie sometimes it's just a
white car with a presence on it I heard
some heard something flip-flopping who
changed their mind very quickly about
this door you're out there I opened the
door on purpose uh-huh sure yeah sure
hey come play with me
uh-huh okay come play with me okay
you're both still running around outside
you're not gonna fit in the window oh
you figured it out you got a Crouch
that's the ticket yes I figured it out
all right yeah you close that door mark
no you go back out there mark yeah you
go back in that stairwell mark where I
am I think I have a no no no no book
shelf is mark yeah you look at that
bookshelf mark yeah all right yeah now
you're oh now you look where that plane
is look at the other bookshelf mark yeah
that's the ticket wait oh wait you're
not you're just a crate what do I see
moved out I'm definitely not in that
room hmm
I'm also definitely not in this
stairwell what the hell I saw you for a
split second you matter is a [ __ ] and
it's roars yes wait literally just
climbed in the window over me well I
climbed in the window window the window
window the wind yes yes that's the words
I climbed you come like your club like
plumbing holes I'm sorry
yeah I'm not in that part of the inside
you dumbass Hey
my rocket my rocket I had it I had him
Oh clearly you did not sir Oh Terry
where's this map 10 rounds long no ten
rounds alone we're all eager they are
sure they are we are on - two points Bob
yeah that's fine they killed themselves
what's the time anyway no uh no huh no
all meant by that you better mean us
absolutely yeah good show some respect
yeah respect it's the thing that we
deserve probably our all right [ __ ] that
like you're inside already Jack cause
like I found one already
all right they're already inside mark be
careful okay are you inside they're
definitely inside no we inside they
don't worry.i goodly we're inside
something well I'm inside something I
don't know about Wade hey are you taking
me
well okay first I'll give you a tour of
my my new house
yes I'll wait for you I'm waiting ring
hang on I'm stuck on this box hang on
okay yeah good so check out my new crib
there's splashing around oh hey Jack
this is the door Oh Jack's coming -
welcome to my crib don't mind the boxes
I I didn't know you guys were coming
today
but uh this is the the plant are their
numbers those are my secrets
you guys are taking but that's okay
it's Christmas Easter around here I love
you sir I got it it is uh we call him
TCT he's tiny crab Tim that's all copy
tiny box Tim - name him
that's what we call PCT to keep it uh
you getting a front-row seat at all this
yeah I'm seeing it I got eyes on oh
sorry I was just cleaning up I was
moving that kid over to my apartment
here's the bookshelves we actually keep
books this is a stupid bookshelf where a
weird way where do I keep my bullets why
would you why would you waste bullets
why would you waste bullets on Christmas
you guys seem a little hostile I think
you guys need a snack so oh okay and
there's uh let's see what else we got
[Laughter]
just you and me now Jack just you and me
[Music]
sure he did mention that he has a
roommate and Mark I actually saw you at
one point as we were making our way to
the apartment oh I know what do we have
I was so worried that you're gonna give
up jack kill yourself yeah that's a good
how it works when I give up yeah inside
or outside I'm inside it's the merriest
Christmas of all we wish you a Merry
Christmas we wish you a Merry Christmas
we wish you a Merry Christmas and happy
[Laughter]
you always had me all over the backwater
Merry Christmas everyone
[Music]
[Music]